talk to vaccines minister nadim zahawi
good to see you
as always look can we start with with
what we heard from the prime minister
last night i mean obviously there's very
positive news that he confirmed he had
easing of restrictions
next week but i mean he he was a bit
slim on the detail of
how we move forward i mean in particular
things like the vaccine passports the
certification
we don't actually know how that's going
to be rolled out do we
good morning stephen i think it's
important to
just remember what the prime minister
said uh yesterday
that next monday you can go to a beer
garden and have
your beer there is no requirements for
uh
vaccine certification or passports that
are being referred to
in may you'll be able to go inside uh
the pub and enjoy
your drink and there is no uh question
of a vaccine
uh certification being asked for so i
just want to sort of allay some of those
uh fears now uh we need to unpack this a
little bit
for your viewers international travel a
number of countries have already
indicated that they're going to require
some form of certification
as they do now as we require a
pre-departure test certificate
so it's important that we make sure that
operationally
that the protocols are you know designed
and work in a way that's really
advantageous to our citizens
which is why the task force looking at
this
is working through those protocols at
the same time as the nhs
is operationally making it viable so if
people do
need their certificate if and when
it is appropriate uh for them to travel
then they'll be able to have
that certification uh available to them
that's only right
now use of certification domestically
does throw up a number of
difficult ethical questions which is why
michael gove's been consulting with
businesses with stakeholders with
colleagues in parliament
so that we listen to all sorts of views
now it would be completely remiss
and irresponsible of government i'd be
coming on your program and you'd be
saying to me
you know we've seen this work in in
europe we've seen it work in israel
why haven't we thought about this why
are we behind uh
other countries so it's only appropriate
and right
that we make sure that the technology
the operations
are available and ready to go for
international
travel as and when that is okay forget
forgive me for jumping in forgive me for
jumping in the international travel and
we
will talk about travel a bit more in a
moment but i think a lot of people would
understand that the domestic issue
does cause some concern the prime
minister didn't rule out
uh passports for pubs last night you
seem to be saying this morning that that
is not going to be the case
but if you can say that category
categorically about
going inside to the pub from may onwards
then then why can't you say what's going
to be happening with things like
restaurants with things like
cinemas and and concert venues
so he he said that yesterday about next
monday
in a pub garden uh in may inside a pub
he's made that very clear but we're also
piloting
a large scale public
whether it be sports events like the uh
fa cup finals semi-final
or other events to look at how whether
it's testing
or vaccination or immunity
to the virus can help us open up
more of our economy it's only
responsible that we look at the
all the available data
and of course all the available routes
for us to get our lives back
as quickly as possible that is only what
you'd expect from us because if you know
if we're not doing this and we see it
working in other countries
the first thing you'd be doing is saying
why haven't you thought of this why
didn't you look at that
and that's only you know the right thing
to do and a responsible thing to do as a
government
is it going to be so but are you going
down the path of saying
you know if it is going to be required
it's going to be an enforceable
requirement or are you
going along the lines of it's going to
be up to some venues to decide what they
what they want to do well i think as the
prime minister said i'm going to
sort of plagiarize it you're jumping too
many fences at the same time what we're
saying is
that for international travel if our
citizens
need to travel at the right time when
obviously international travel
returns we will make sure that they're
able to demonstrate their
certification whether it be a
pre-departure test certificate
or a vaccination test certificate
domestically
the the the the step two which we're
coming
up to step three there will be
absolutely
no issue around uh pubs or restaurants
requiring any form
of certification but it's only
responsible
as we see how this virus behaves as we
see
how other countries are utilizing
technologies
to make sure that they keep the virus
under control then we should look at the
same thing it's only the right thing to
do we're all
working towards the same outcome which
is to get our lives back
get our economy running whilst
this is this is all about clarity not
only for these businesses but for the
the consumers who who use them and we're
getting it to be fair we're getting
information from you some clarity that
we didn't get from the pm last night so
you're saying when
when things reopen like going inside to
a pub
going inside to a restaurant going
inside to
a cinema or for example because
obviously cinemas are looking to reopen
in may
you were saying are you that at this
point in time there is absolutely no
requirement that you're expecting
for a passport to be required of a covid
passport to be required
to be fair that's exactly what the pm
clarified last night he said
that when you go to the pub garden on
monday uh you'll be able to sip your
pint without requiring
any form of uh certification when you go
inside the pub
on may the 17th if we continue to
obviously make sure we look at the data
there's four weeks plus one remember
that we are going to make sure to keep
on top of this virus by make sure
making sure we keep looking at the data
you won't be needing
that uh covered vaccine certification
but we are looking at piloting large
scale events
like the fa cup final initially looking
at testing using testing as the
technology
but also looking at other ways including
immunity
and of course vaccines as a way of
making sure we take as much of our lives
back as quickly as possible
if you continue to have your target as
being
working together to get our lives back
to get the economy up and running
then you won't get this wrong okay um
look um
what is very important it falls within
your remit that i really need to ask
about is
is the the regulatory authority raising
some concerns
about astrazeneca the the oxford
astrozenica jab
being given to the under 30s now we know
some research
has shown perhaps an elevated risk of a
blood clot
in younger people is it your
understanding that this is now being
looked at
so the mhra uh led by june reign have
been
looking at this uh all the time they
have
always made sure that they look at all
incidents with
all the vaccines that will be deployed
we're currently deploying at scale
pfizer and of course the
oxford zenica and they've been very
clear that the benefits
of the vaccine far outweigh
any of these rare incidents
of risk and if you get the call to take
your vaccine
but of course we will be guided by the
mhra by the joint committee on
vaccination
immunization as they continue to look at
these very
rare incidents uh and i think that's
only right and of course
just as a sort of reminder to your
viewers the mhra is independent of
government and they publish
through the yellow card system all
incidents as they did
last week as they're going to do again
so that's important
we've led the largest and probably one
of the most successful vaccination
programs
in the world the confidence that
vaccination program is because we have
such a
robust regulatory framework in the
united kingdom i think that's important
to remember as well and and june rain
last night
uh made it very clear that if you get
your uh invitation please come forward
between december stephen and the end of
february
the vaccination program has saved 6
300 people over 70 from dying so that
puts it in perspective
oh absolutely absolutely it does but but
we're not talking about
and under unless it's under very
specific health reasons we're not
talking about calling the under 30s up
to get their vaccine
just yet and we know that different
vaccines have different strengths and
weaknesses within different
age groups i mean that is scientifically
understood
so it is it prudent at this point to be
looking in detail now
at whether under 30s when it comes to be
their turn
need to be given a different vaccine
well as i said
the regulator uh continues as does the
european regulator and the who
to recommend that the astronomical
opposite vaccine be given
to all uh ages over 18.
they continue to obviously monitor and
look very carefully
at these very rare cases of blood
clotting
um again another perspective on this
we've done almost 20 million
uh vaccinations using the oxygen
acidvinica
vaccine and they make sure that they
they
look at each and every adverse incident
that
occurs at the moment they're very very
clear to say that if you get your
invite please come forward and take the
vaccine because it
protects you protects your family
protects your community we saw some data
from chris whitty
yesterday demonstrating the efficacy of
these vaccines but the
we will be led my my deployment team
will be led by what the
regulator what the scientists uh tell us
is the right thing to do we've got other
vaccines
um coming along including the modern
vaccine very shortly and then of course
the jansen j and j
vaccine and more pfizer and more
oxidative seneca so we
we are in uh in a good place uh because
of what decision that matt hancock and
uh and
boris johnson took very early on last
year to make sure that we have the
vaccines available to us to be able to
protect the whole nation and i'm
confident
by the end of your life look just to
just to change
uh track just to finish with over this
whole david cameron
green sill issue which is causing
concern about the transparency of
lobbying and what is go you know what
happens
within the corridors of power you were
in the policy unit
when lex greenstill seemed to have this
rather strange rather unique access to
number 10
with his own business card and
government email address and everything
else
i mean did you think that was normal at
the time did you raise any concerns with
you
well i'd never met lex greenstill um
during my work in the possibly or since
then
um the job he was doing unpaid
was to look at supply chains for the
then prime minister david cameron
all the uh usual approvals would have
been
gone through to be able to appoint him
as that
supply chain advisor to the prime
minister and i think
that's important we have got you know
the checks and balances in place
uh that take place in terms of any
approvals of any advisor to any prime
minister
and i think that's important to remind
the your viewers of that